all right so I quit my job I quit my job
as an associate Solutions architect
working at AWS this decision was not an
easy one at all because in AWS I really
liked my team I like the work I was
doing and for the most part I had a
great time it felt like almost 10 years
in the company even though I've only
been there for two and a half years and
that just goes to show how much I was
able to learn and develop and build up
my technical skills as well as make an
impact on things that I was passionate
about I got to help out a lot of
customers and I also got to start
programs internally within the company
on early career initiatives and women in
Tech and so I really found it hard to
say goodbye to everyone but the reason I
decided to leave is to actually do
YouTube full-time this YouTube channel
is almost like my second identity so
five days a week I was a Solutions
architect and on the weekends I would be
Tech with Lucy and record videos write
scripts and edit and publish them so it
was almost as if I had two identities
for the past two years in my career and
what I really liked is how these two
identities really complemented Each
Other Well my YouTube channel helped me
with my personal branding at work and it
was great to meet people at work who
have come across a child and go like
wait you're taking Lucy I thought that
was pretty cool and also what I was
learning at work and my perspective as a
Solutions architect was really helpful
in making videos for the tech with Lucy
Channel and in turn that helped a lot of
people land a job in the cloud industry
and helped people get a degree certified
and build the technical skills as you
can tell I really liked both sides of
this two-part identity so both the
solutions Arctic role and my role as a
content creator on YouTube and so for
the longest time I did both I worked
seven days a week and whenever I had
free time after work I would plan out
the next video idea but what ended up
happening was as my responsibilities I
worked continued to increase and my
YouTube videos continue to require more
effort and time as well I found it
extremely hard to balance both it came
to a point where I really had to just
take a step back and ask myself do I
want YouTube to be a side Hobby and
something that I'll continue to do
alongside my role or do I potentially
want to do YouTube full-time
so here comes the question why did I
choose to do YouTube full-time as
opposed to keeping it as a side Hobby
and focusing on my main career well
first of all YouTube is just really
really fun for me I really like the
creative process behind making videos
you know storytelling thinking about a
way to teach something in a way that's
easy to understand it's something that I
really enjoy that whole process but also
when people watch the videos and get
value out of it the cool thing about
YouTube compared to other platforms is
that once you make a video it can
continue to show up in search for months
and years afterwards and that brings me
on to the second reason potential and
impact what I feel like I'm doing with
YouTube is I'm building a repository of
information to help people build their
technical skills and land a job in the
cloud industry I base all of my videos
off of suggestions from all of you so
you know when you leave a comment down
below and let me know what type of
videos you want to see I looked through
the videos I find the most commonly
asked questions and I make a video about
it so over the past two years of making
videos my viewers actually want to see I
feel like I've really built trust in the
tech with Lucy community and when I
decided to quit my job the channel was
growing at around a thousand subscribers
a week I really believe there's
potential to do even more whether that's
making videos more frequently on YouTube
or branching out into other platforms
like Tick Tock or Instagram there's just
so many ideas going around in my head
all the time and I wanted to dedicate
some time to work on YouTube full-time
so that I could actually flesh out some
of these ideas and turn it into reality
the final reason is money and this blows
my mind to say but currently the YouTube
business pays me more than what I was
getting at AWS so part of the money is
from YouTube themselves when they show
ads before my videos and at the end or
maybe in the middle as well and the main
portion comes from Brand deals and
sponsorships so if you've seen me
promote a product maybe like a free AWS
course these companies I collaborate
with would pay me a one-off fee so with
this business model I'll be able to
continue to make free content for the
community whilst having a full-time
income
as I was recording this video someone
sent me a message they asked me don't
you think it was a mistake to leave AWS
I mean how you feel is important of
course but to me you're leaving a
position that many people dream of but
will never reach a position with
security and benefits essentially you
know why leave for a trending YouTube
channel this is quite interesting and a
few people have asked me this already
YouTube yeah it might not be around
forever and there's no guarantee that my
YouTube business will just keep growing
and you know continue to succeed at some
point there may be a decline or maybe at
some point I want to go back to having a
job in the tech industry during my time
at AWS I learned about something called
a one-way door and a two-way door a
one-way door is essentially a decision
where once you make the decision you can
never reverse it and you never go back
to before you made the decision whereas
a two-way door is something where you
make the decision you can trial it out
make a few mistakes and if or else fails
you could go back to where you started
or you can take the learnings and choose
a different path without causing much
damage so I view my decision as a
two-way door I walk in and then I can
come out if it's not right for me or if
something goes wrong I think what's
important as well is just knowing your
value I know that the skills I developed
through this whole YouTube Journey will
still be valuable in the tech industry
if I decide to go back and these types
of risky moves are probably better to do
earlier on in a career as well I've just
turned 23 this year and for example if I
do YouTube for three years I can still
go back into the tech industry and
restart my career
a big thank you to everyone who has been
a part of this journey whether you've
been watching my videos for a while or
maybe you decided to subscribe because
you saw my Twitter post about me leaving
AWS the channel would not be where it is
now without everyone's support I want to
end this video by saying I'm very very
grateful for this opportunity and I know
I'm at a very privileged place to just
quit my job and not worry about the
financial side and the long-term future
of my career as always please give this
video a like to help out the channel and
I'll see you in the comments below bye
for now